when we think of Halloween we think of a
fun and spooky holiday for those of all
ages the streets are filled of adults
and children in all sorts of costumes
from terrifying monsters to figures of
history and of course Harley Quinn you
can't even turn a corner without seeing
at least 5 Harley Quinn's we attend
horror themed events and we decorate our
houses in anticipation for the endless
horde of trick-or-treaters that await
their candy some prefer to stay indoors
and binge on horror movie marathons and
others actively seek a thrill with
haunted houses and mazes become an
extremely popular today we aim to
uncover the origins of Halloween how its
traditions came to pass and why the
holiday is loved by so many
it is thought that Halloween originated
in Celtic Island around 2,000 years ago
with the festival known as soin the
festival itself celebrated the divide of
the two halves of the year summer and
winter light and dark durin soin the
veils between this world and the other
world were at their thinnest allowing
spirits to pass through families would
invite lost loved ones and ancestors
into their homes to share in their
celebrations and in order to avoid harm
from evil spirits they would wear
costumes and masks to disguise
themselves
the Druids built large sacred bonfires
in order to honor the dead and to
protect the living animals were
sacrificed than a year's harvest was
prepared for both the living and the
dead with the food made for the dead
ritually shared between those who were
less well-off the Christians believe
that soin was a pagan holiday and
because of the festival's association
with death the Celtic people and druids
were labelled as devil worshipers in
their attempts to wipe out pagan
practices the Christians succeeded in
transforming the festival into All
Saints Day or more commonly known as All
Hallows day the night before
traditionally known as soin became All
Hallows Eve and eventually Halloween so
where have some of these modern day
traditions originated from we know that
dressing up during Halloween originated
from the Celts who dressed up as evil
spirits to avoid harm from other evil
spirits during soin although
trick-or-treating today mainly consists
of children running around on sugar
highs collecting as much candy as
humanly possible that wasn't always the
case in medieval Britain during the All
Souls Day Festival the poor and those in
need would beg for food and would often
be given salted pastries made from
sacred flour and water these were named
soul cakes in return they would pray for
relatives who had passed away
the young would also dress up in costume
and they would go door to door
collecting food and sometimes even money
in exchange they would sing recite
poetry and tell jokes these traditions
were eventually revived in 19th century
America by the Irish and Scottish
migrants in the form we know today as
trick-or-treat in its early days the
focus was very much on the trick with
pranks and vandalism being commonplace
the town leaders eventually managed to
limit the vandalism during Halloween
when they decided to make the holiday
center around the young first you make a
hole at the top so you can reach in and
scoop all the guts out so why exactly do
we carve pumpkins we've come to know
them as jack-o'-lanterns but their
origins date back to the 17th century
where their name meant man of a lantern
and would often refer to the
Nightwatchman of a town the tale of
stingy jack is believed to be where the
tradition began when Jack died he was
denied entry into heaven and having
previously angered the devil he was also
not allowed into hell instead the devil
sent jack into eternal darkness with
only a turnip field of coal to light his
way the Irish and Scottish people began
carving creepy faces into turnips and
placing them by their windows in order
to scare stingy Jack and other evil
spirits away when they continued the
tradition in America they found an
abundance of pumpkins and decided that
these would make a great substitute for
turnips whether you believe that
jack-o'-lanterns keep away evil spirits
or not they have become a staple
decoration and symbol of Halloween even
a game as trivial as bobbing for apples
once had more of a significance in
Ireland and Scotland apple bobbing was
used to tell one's fortune as part of
the divination game you would throw an
apple poo on the floor and the shape of
the pillow would determine the initial
of a future lover
there's no argument to the fact that
Halloween has changed over the years
it appears have lost its religious
origins and the superstitions
surrounding it play little or no part in
today's version of the holiday despite
how commercialized the holiday has
become it remains one of the most
popular one of the main reasons I enjoy
Halloween is because it gives people of
all ages the chance to come together for
one evening
to celebrate the supernatural we allow
imaginations to run wild and embrace
creativity there are no limits or
boundaries to whom or what you can
become if you've enjoyed this video then
please consider leaving a thumbs up as
it helps promote the video and allows
the channel to grow if there's anything
you'd like to discuss or have any ideas
for future videos then please let me
know in the comment section as always
I've been your host mythology and
folklore explain